today we're going to prove this result
within the topic of complex numbers now
before i show you the solution i thought
i would kind of peel back the veil a
little bit
and give you a bit of insight into my
thinking process because when i
first looked at this question the
solution didn't just sort of jump out at
me some questions
are very familiar they're quite routine
it's like i have an algorithm in my head
for automatically how to do these
and we like to call those as math
teachers we like to call those
exercises it's like you know how to do
this you know what the steps are you
just
go ahead and sort of you know
regurgitate your memory for how this
process goes
but alongside exercises where you know
what the answer is or at least how to
get there
we also encounter these things called
problems and problems
are not so neat they aren't like oh
here's the five steps that you go
through every time you encounter
a question like this problems are much
more interesting because the
solution path it doesn't immediately
present yourself
itself to you or it might be just a
little more unfamiliar
now doing those questions is really
important because they help you
actually think it's when you do problems
it's when you attend problems that you
actually have to consider
different alternatives different ways of
solving the problem and so as a result
you learn
a lot more they hurt your brain a bit
more but they're a lot more beneficial
so what i want to do is unpack for you a
bit of the thinking process that
happened to me
before i actually arrived at my solution
because that will show you like the
the dead ends that i kind of went
through were in fact not dead ends they
were a really important part of the
logic i used
to arrive in my actual solution so
that's enough of a preamble let's have a
go at interpreting the question
understanding
how to solve it if z1 and z2 are complex
numbers such that the modulus of z1
equals the modulus of z2
prove that and then we have this result
to do with the arguments of
apparently the product of z1 and z2 and
then
the square of the sum of z1 and z2 so
how do we go about this and the first
thing that sort of came up to me was
that this result this thing this
connection to do with the arguments
it isn't always true this is not
universally the case
it's true on a condition and you can see
the condition provided to you right in
the side of the question
this is only true if you've got this
situation where the moduli
of your two complex numbers that you're
considering z1 and z2 if the moduli are
equal
then this is actually true so i thought
well
a natural place to start is to uh use
this as kind of our foundation
our logical sort of basis and then sort
of develop from there
so the first thing that i wrote down was
well z1 equals z2
that's that's the first piece of data
they've given us but then
i can consider z1 and z2 as complex
numbers in a variety of different forms
we've got
rectangular or cartesian form we've got
polar or trigonometric form
and then we've got exponential form and
often
one of the things that we want you to
learn as you attempt these questions
is that some forms are more helpful than
others depending on the kind of question
you're trying to solve and so i thought
to myself which
is the most useful of the forms for this
particular question
when you have a look at the result
that's being asked to be proven here you
can see it has
arguments in it and then the piece of
information that you're
provided with is to do with moduli so
therefore
i would think rectangular form which
tells me the horizontal and vertical
coordinates
for these complex numbers will be less
useful i want a form of the complex
numbers that has to do with
the modulus and the argument so that
would either be polar trigonometric form
or exponential form now both of those
are pretty closely related and they both
have the same piece of information
written there
the modulus out the front as r and then
the argument theta over in either the
trigonometric terms or in the
exponential
uh in the exponent right so because i'm
a little bit lazy i decided to go with
exponential form because it's slightly
more concise
so this is what i wrote next i said well
if z1 and z2 are two
sort of arbitrary complex numbers and
the only things i know about them
is that they have the same distance from
the origin the same modulus
then i can say they both have this
shared
r so they're equal i don't have to say
there's an r1 and r2
i know from the outset that they're
equal but then i don't know anything
about the angles the angles could be
anything so i've just designated
alpha and beta could be equal to any
kind of angle
so then i started to consider well if
this is my setup this is how i'm framing
z1
and z2 how can i bring this toward the
content of the question
well if if this is my z1 and this is my
z2 then i can actually
fairly straightforwardly evaluate the
left hand side and the right hand side
of this expression and i'm hoping to get
the same thing
so i start at the left hand side because
it's easier when you multiply
these two numbers together to get the
arguments
this is just me taking r e to the i
alpha
and r e to the i beta and just
multiplying them together right so
you of course get your r's multiplying
to give you r squared
and then if you remember your index laws
you can see that
e i to the alpha e i to the e to the i
alpha and e to the i beta both of them
have the same base so we can just add
their indices together so i'm getting
this
r squared e to the power of i alpha plus
i beta
nothing too dramatic so far you can see
at this point when you're working out
the arguments
you want to get the angle there by
factorizing out i
that's how we write the complex the for
the
polar sorry the i'm so confused at the
moment the exponential form
of a complex number so we would say uh
once you've got it in r e to the i theta
form that theta
which is just whatever you get after you
factorize out i that's your angle right
that's your argument
so therefore i get from there to alpha
plus beta
which probably you already saw from the
outset but this is just the working to
get there right
so this is the argument this is what
happens when you multiply complex
numbers together you add their arguments
now we have a look at the right hand
side of the equation which is
a little bit more complicated and see if
we can get something meaningful out of
it right
so this is what happened to me i just
said well i'm just going to take the
right hand side as stated
and then i'm just going to substitute in
my r e to the i alpha my r
e to the i beta this is just a straight
substitution
and then i'm squaring it so therefore i
can actually expand this binomial and
this
is where i landed now this was the point
at which i thought to myself
okay this is true but it doesn't look
especially useful to me because unlike
you can see here with the left hand side
right
the left hand side your e to the i alpha
and your e to the i beta they collapse
into a single e to the
whatever term and so you can read or you
can extract
the argument out of that quite quite
easily which is exactly what we did here
but but you don't get away so easily
here i've got these
r squares hanging out the front sure i
could just factorize them out and
everything will be fine
but then you've got this business
happening i don't really know what to do
with this
you've got these different arguments of
different complex numbers here
but they are connected via addition
not by multiplication now i don't have
like a ready-made result like i do here
or indeed here that when you multiply
complex numbers you add their arguments
well when you add complex numbers that's
what i'm doing here there are three
separate complex numbers here that came
from this binomial expansion
and i'm not multiplying i'm adding them
together
what do you know about the argument of
that sum of complex numbers and the
answer is
i don't know i don't have any ready-made
results like i said before
that will help me so at this point even
though i feel like i got somewhere i
didn't get far enough
i don't i don't see sort of it's not
immediately apparent to me how i'm going
to get this
into here if the question is true which
it is by the way
um i should be able to get there but i
the path is kind of
not immediately apparent so it's a
little bit like i'm in a maze and i've
sort of gone through a few different
turns
and then i haven't ended up at a dead
end but i've gotten to a point where i'm
like i don't know how to progress
from here so at this point i thought um
i'm a little confused
what else could i do what other problem
solving strategies do i have
in my toolbox and i thought to myself
well
can i understand what is going on here
by thinking of a specific example
right this is supposed to be true for
any pair of complex numbers such that
their moduli are the same
so can i think of a pair of complex
numbers that have the same modulus
and then can i understand what does this
actually mean what does it look like
for that example now doing something by
example
is obviously not a proof we want to show
this is true in a general sense not just
for a specific case
but when you have a look at a specific
case as you're about to see often that
specific case can give you insights
that will work generally and that gives
you kind of a path through the question
so let's have a think about some
specific examples of this
this is the easiest example i could
think of of two complex numbers
that are easy to wrap my head around
they have the same argument and then to
see what would the result mean
so i chose my first complex number to be
1 and my second complex number to be i
because then i can quite you know easily
work out what's the product
what's the sum and then what happens
when i square right so here's one
here's i and of course the sum of one
and i is
one plus i so you can see that's where
it sits
on the uh on the complex plane right and
i should have
marked in that this is the imaginary
axis
and this is the real axis so so far so
good
i've got my one plus i which i'm getting
from here
and now you can see if i were to square
this of course i could actually just
use the binomial expansion here and i
could work out what it all ends up to be
equal to
but i don't need to because the thing
that i'm really interested in is just
the argument it's just the angle it's
the argument of
z1 plus ed2 or squared that i need and i
know that because i've chosen nice and
easy numbers
i've got an argument here of pi on 4.
so when i multiply this 1 plus i by
itself
i'm going to add the argument to itself
so it's going to give me an
argument of pi on 2. 1 plus i or squared
is going to be off
somewhere up here maybe something like
that from
you know just working out i think you're
going to get 2i that's what happens when
you
multiply the the 1 squared and the i
squared cancel out just leaving the 2i
in the middle
so you can see this is going to be
argument i get when i
uh add an n square which is
you know by inspection the same as the
argument you're going to get when you
multiply right z1 times z2
because i chose such easy values that
just gives you i
and i of course it also has an argument
of pi on 2.
so it works okay but
this is a very easy example can i kind
of generalize further by looking at
you know this is a very you know really
convenient numbers can i go further
what i decided to do was not go too much
further
1 and i are nice because they both sit
on the unit circle
i can consider other numbers on the unit
circle that means they'll have
the same modulus moduli but i can think
of some more interesting and exotic
examples no it doesn't need to be much
more exotic to see a bit of a point
so what i did was next i considered
let's let's keep
i that's uh you know it's still simple
but not too
as simple as 1. and let's consider a
number like
minus 1 and root 2 minus 1 and root 2i
now why did i choose that
and that's because i chose something
which was off in a different quadrant um
to see if i could understand what was
going on so when you draw this thing out
this is what you get
right in fact i can just delete this
what's going on here
well here's my z1 and here's my z2
and in order to work out what z1 plus z2
is i'm thinking of these think back to
you know the earlier topic in in complex
numbers i'm thinking about visualizing
each of these complex numbers
as a vector right so you can see here z1
can be considered
as a vector from the origin up to i so
in other words that's just a vertical
translation
of exactly one unit that's how you get
to i on the complex plane
so therefore to do z1 plus z2
i can say well it's like doing z2 and
then adding z1 which is to go up one
unit
in the vertical direction on the complex
plane so you can see that's why i've
marked in this blue dotted line as
plus z1 that's me going upwards just
like
this plus z1 is doing and um that makes
this result here
z2 plus z1 strictly speaking but
addition is commutative so i can switch
the order so this is where my number is
okay
z1 plus s2 now at this point i thought
to myself
okay i think i understand what is going
on because
i've got an angle here if you think
about
this angle around here this is the
argument
of z1 plus z2
and if i were to square z one plus said
two
it would go double the way around so
where is it going to end me it's going
to end around
um if i do that angle all the way over
again
i think it's going to end up here
right and you can see that is going to
give you the same result as
what would happen if you took this and
you added
the argument for z1 because that's what
happens when you multiply z1z2
z1 times z2 you add the arguments so i'm
going to start from here
and then i'm going to add the pi on 2
that you got here so you can see
this pi on 2 here i'm adding to here so
you can see it's just
going forward a little bit and so you
can see here the reason why this works
is because this angle for z1 plus a2 in
the first place
do you see that it's exactly halfway
between z1
and z2 there's actually a bisection of
that angle happening
so in fact this is where the light bulb
moment for me was there's actually
geometry
underneath this the reason why i wasn't
able to get very far
with this algebraic approach is because
i'm trying to understand these
angles and these lengths z1 and z2 being
the same
i'm trying to deal with them in strictly
algebraic terms which means i'm not
thinking about what they mean
geometrically it's possible but it can
be quite hard and you can see it's quite
finicky to do that's why i didn't get
very far
okay now once i saw this once i realized
there was a bisection happening and that
i could think about this geometrically
that's when the lights turned on for me
and i finally arrived at
not just some specific examples where
this works but an actual
solution so that's what i'm about to
show you but before i do that
i just want you to hit pause on this
video if you didn't think about doing
this
geometrically hit pause before i show
you the answer and see if you can have a
go at
what would you construct how would you
do this in general terms remember what
you're looking at right now
is all in terms of specific complex
numbers like 1 and i
or i and minus 1 on root 2 minus 1 and
root 2i
this won't cut it for a proof that's
general
how would you construct a diagram and
then use some
deductive logic some geometric logic to
try
and prove this true for any z1 and z2
so long as they share the same modulus
have a think about that i wonder if what
i've shown you is enough of
a nudge if there's enough clues